- Today, you will be
with steel harvested
from this hedgehog
combining it with the
1095 on your anvils
to form your blades--
the combat knife.
You will have three hours
to forge your blades.
Good luck.
Your three hours starts now.
So we've got our four veterans
scurrying about the forge
looking to harvest some steel.
Do you expect that
these guys are
going to work in teams, Doug?
Absolutely.
Even though this is an
individual competition,
in the military,
we work as a team.
I love the idea of
doing a combat knife.
Wow.
This [bleep] is thick.
Watch your feet when
that bad boy drops.
You watch yours.
I didn't listen
to my own advice.
WILL: Mike, you're
our only marine.
I know.
So what do you
think of when you hear
fighting knife or combat knife?
- Marine Corps-- KA-BAR.
- KA-BAR.
Exactly what I think.
How do you plan on
forge-welding your steel?
I'm going to do a
.
All right, brother.
Damn it.
WILL: Mike's
[inaudible] looks rough.
Not only is it duck-lipping,
but the lips are sliding.
Yeah, shifting.
[bleep] me.
When I do Damascus I have
a 50% failure rate because
forge-welding is not my staple.
But I learned not to
chase turds by getting
smacked a whole bunch
of times by the master
bladesmith I learned from.
Screw it.
Rule one-- abandon.
Chuck it.
Done.
Start over.
WILL: We are almost one
hour into this first round
of competition, and
Mike is starting over.
Oh, now we're
doing the hard part--
waiting for it to
get up to weld temp.
That sucks, man.
MIKE: Oh, man, I'm way behind.
Seeing where they're
at and mine is
still in the fire getting hot.
What can I do?
Nothing.
So I'm standing at the
forge and that sense of,
what's happening here?
I actually start to
feel pressure in my jaw,
in my left arm.
It just seems to snowball on me.
All right, hold on.
The medic's on the floor.
Perry, are you all right?
Is the world's spinning on you?
Yeah.
Perry's just locked up.
Let's go behind here.
Oh.
The world's spinning on you?
Yeah.
He's going down.
MEDIC: Sit down,
sit down, sit down.
Perry, sit up.
Here's what you got
to respect about Perry.
He worked until he
couldn't stand anymore,
and there's a lot to be said
for that kind of tenacity.
30 minutes, bladesmiths.
You have 30 minutes
remaining in this round.
In case you didn't notice,
Perry has been medical dropped,
but that's not a free pass.
Your blades still
need to be up to par.
Mike is back on track.
Oh yeah.
I set my weld on a second one
and everything is phenomenal.
I am in my zone and I'm
just letting the steel
take me on a beautiful trip.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, shut
down your machines.
Drop your tools.
This round is over.
Just because we've
had a medical drop
doesn't mean that you
all get a free pass.
You still have to fulfill
the mission parameters.
John, you're up first.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
The steel looks good.
I think the profile of your
knife's really good looking.
Our only marine.
Mike, please present
your blade to the judges.
First up, good job
knowing when to start over.
This looks like a very
nice slashing weapon.
Thrusting wise, with a
trailing point over there,
you have to adjust, so you want
to be able to have a little bit
more of an angle
that comes to a point
to where I don't have to adjust.
All right, Jim.
You're up.
Classic spear point.
Great cutting, great
thrusting design.
Big concern for me is this seam
going right down the middle
of the spine in your knife.
But I love the shape of it.
Nice job.
Thank you, sir.
OK, bladesmiths.
The judges have completed
their deliberation
and they've made
a final decision.
The judges agree that you
all have passed parameters,
and you will be moving
on to round two.
Congratulations.